It's never too early to get excited for the
next big blockbuster, right?
From a bevy of superheroes to re-imaginings
of your favorite classics, clear your calendar
all the way through 2019, because here are
just a few of the big-budget flicks you're
going to want to get on line for now.
Hellboy
Stranger Things star David Harbour will unveil
his new take on Hellboy in January 2019, joining
director Neil Marshall for what's described
as a gritty take on the original Mike Mignola
comics.
Harbour has said the movie will use a "darker
tone" to differentiate itself from Guillermo
del Toro's adaptations, adding that it'll
be more of "a character piece" about Hellboy's
struggle.
While Harbour's take on Hellboy looks spot
on, the rest of the cast is also packed with
potential, including Milla Jovovich as the
villainous Blood Queen, Ian McShane as Hellboy's
adopted father, and Sasha Lane as Alice Monaghan.
The movie also has signed Lost's Daniel Dae
Kim to play comics favorite Major Ben Daimio.
The real question, however, is if there'll
be pancakes.
Glass
M. Night Shyamalan continues his surprise
superhero trilogy with Glass, a sequel to
2017's Split, whose final act unexpectedly
tied in with 2000's Unbreakable.
The movie will bring back all the main players
from both films, including Bruce Willis, Samuel
L. Jackson, James McAvoy, and Anya Taylor-Joy.
Details are still under wraps, and given how
much Shyamalan loves twists, it'll probably
stay that way until the film's January 2019
release date.
Silver and Black
Sony's Spider-Man universe gets a female-led
entry in February 2019 with Silver and Black,
headed by The Secret Life of Bees director
Gina Prince-Bythewood, who also directed Marvel's
Cloak and Dagger pilot for Freeform.
She'll also assist with the script, alongside
Thor: Ragnarok's Chris Yost.
The movie is set to follow Marvel's mercenary
Silver Sable and the burglar Black Cat in
a pairing that Prince-Bythewood compares to
Thelma and Louise.
The dark film will reportedly bring in the
cyborg supervillain Gaunt, and his enforcers
Tarantula and Scorpion as the villains.
Yep, this guy.
"I beat Spider-Man!
Taken out by the one… the only…
Scorpion!"
Chaos Walking
Your next favorite YA adaptation will hit
theaters in March 2019 with Chaos Walking,
a sci-fi adventure based on the trilogy by
Patrick Ness.
The movie takes place on a planet where almost
all the women have been killed off by a virus
and living creatures can hear each other's
thoughts.
As the story begins, a young man played by
Tom Holland meets a woman played by Daisy
Ridley... and she may have the key to unlocking
the world's many secrets.
Though it's not as if Daisy Ridley as a girl
with mysterious powers is much of a stretch.
The movie has an amazing supporting cast that
includes Oscar nominee Demian Bichir, two-time
Golden Globe nominee David Oyelowo, Tony winner
Cynthia Erivo, critical favorite Mads Mikkelsen,
and pop star Nick Jonas.
Mark your calendars now.
Dumbo
Disney has given a number of animated classics
the live-action treatment, but one of the
most intriguing is Tim Burton's Dumbo, starring
Colin Farrell as Holt, a former circus performer
whose life is turned upside down after he
returns home from the war.
Holt teams up with circus owner Max Medici,
played by Danny DeVito, to care for a newborn
elephant whose giant ears have already made
him a laughingstock.
The movie's all-star cast also includes Michael
Keaton, Alan Arkin, and Eva Green.
With Burton and a whole host of amazing actors
on board, this should be a worthy retelling
of the classic tale when it's released in
March 2019… probably without these guys.
The Voyage of Doctor Dolittle
Putting down his Iron Man helmet for a while,
Robert Downey Jr. will put his stamp on the
legendary character of Doctor Dolittle in
April of 2019.
The Voyage of Doctor Dolittle, like its predecessors,
will also be based on Hugh Lofting's original
children's books.
The movie comes from a script by Syriana's
Stephen Gaghan, who's also set to direct.
Plot details are unknown, but we can only
hope Downey gets the chance to use his glorious
pipes should the movie end up being a musical
like the 1967 original.
Aladdin
Guy Ritchie will reveal his "ambitious and
non-traditional' take on Aladdin in May of
2019, with Mena Massoud taking on the title
role alongside Power Rangers star Naomi Scott
as Jasmine, who landed their roles after beating
out thousands of hopefuls in a worldwide casting
call.
The rest of the cast includes Will Smith stepping
into Robin Williams' role as the Genie and
Marwan Kenzari playing the villainous Jafar.
The cast also includes Saturday Night Live's
Nasim Pedrad and Into the Woods' Billy Magnussen.
We have trust in the Disney machine to make
this a magical trip to the theater.
Cowboy Ninja Viking
Chris Pratt made a very quick journey from
Parks and Recreation schlub to action hero,
and his big June 2019 outing will find the
actor taking the lead in Cowboy Ninja Viking,
based on the Image Comics series of the same
name.
This time, Pratt is a new kind of assassin
who's able to combine the skills of three
legendary kinds of heroes.
It's been a long time in the making.
Pratt first signed on in 2014, but when he
was unable to film due to his hectic schedule,
a couple directors dropped out, waylaying
things further.
Still, with script work from Deadpool's Rhett
Reese and Paul Wernick and The Hangover II's
Craig Mazin, this ridiculous premise has a
pretty good shot at paying off.
When are ninjas NOT entertaining?
Top Gun 2
Maverick will be back in July 2019.
Oblivion director Joseph Kosinski is set to
reunite with Tom Cruise for the long-awaited
Top Gun sequel, which will be set in the world
of drone technology and fifth generation fighters—and
the end of the era of dogfighting.
Producer Jerry Bruckheimer is on board to
return for the sequel, and while it's unclear
whether other actors from the original cast
will be back, Val Kilmer has said he's ready
to step up should he get the call.
Artemis Fowl
Millions of readers remember Eoin Colfer's
Artemis Fowl novels, or their graphic novel
adaptations, which followed precocious criminal
mastermind Artemis through a series of fantastic
adventures around the globe.
The books are ripe for the film franchise
treatment, with Kenneth Branagh set to direct
an adaptation, scheduled to arrive in theaters
in August 2019.
While no casting announcements have been made
yet, this looks like a family-friendly film
saga in the making.
Gemini Man
Will Smith fans have more than just Aladdin
to look forward to in October of 2019.
The actor is also set to star in Ang Lee's
Gemini Man as an aging assassin trying to
get out of the business.
Things get complicated when he has to fight
against his own, much younger clone.
Gemini was first pitched to Disney over twenty
years ago, but the execs had to wait until
visual effects could effectively change the
age of the lead actor.
This promises to be a futuristic action thriller
with a nifty twist—and twice as many Smiths
is never a bad thing.
Or is it?
"Sharks have been around for longer than trees.
That one's hard to believe, but it's actually
true."
James Bond 25
Daniel Craig returns just one more time as
James Bond in the character's 25th feature
film in November 2019.
Blade Runner 2049's Denis Villeneuve, Hell
or High Water's David Mackenzie, and '71's
Yann Demange are reportedly the frontrunners
to direct.
A lot about the movie is still being hammered
out right now, but none of it threatens to
revoke 007's long-standing license to kill
at the box office.
Wonder Woman 2
As the DCEU's highest-grossing film to date
in the U.S., it makes sense that Warner Bros.
quickly ordered a sequel to Wonder Woman,
set to be released in December of 2019.
The movie will also bring back director Patty
Jenkins as co-writer.
While plot details have been kept tightly
under wraps, Jenkins has said she'd like the
film to bring Diana to America after the events
of Wonder Woman, and before Dawn of Justice.
The sequel is also reportedly said to have
found a way to bring back Chris Pine, so look
forward to more action, fun, and maybe even
a supervillain without a silly mustache.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!